OT
SEN B I
PRIN, HE
DESTROYED HIS ANKLE MONITOR, THE
ONE HE WAS REQUIRED TO WEAR FOR
THE DAY HE DIED, HE HAD AN OPEN
CASE FOR DOMESTICSE.
THEY ARE DEFENDING THIS GUY JUST
HOURS BEFORE HE THREATENED TO
KILL KYLE RITTENHOUSE, HE HAD
BEEN RELEAD FROM A MENTAL
HOSPITAL TREATED FOR SOME SORT
OF DISORDER, HE TRIEDO GO BACK
TO HIS FIANCEE BUT SHE HAD A NO
CONTACT ORDER AFTER SHE PRESSED
CHARGES AGAINST HIM A MONTH
EARLIER FOR HITTING HER.
SO THIS IS THE MAN THEY WERE
TELLING IT WAS A MODEL CITIZEN.
>> LET ME JUST REMINDEOPLE OF
THE NAMES OF THE VICTIMS,
ANTHONY HOOV WAS 26, PAGE ONLY
27 YEARS OLDUT INJURED, THESE
ARE THE VICTIMS, THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE THE PEOPLE WHO WERE HURT
HERE I'M NOT THE PERSON CRYING
ON THE STAND TODAY.
>> Tucker: IF YOU ARE AN
HONEST PROGRESSIVE, WHEN YOU ASE
PEOPLE DOING AT A JOE BIDEN
RALLY THREE DAYS AFTER THE
DEMOCRATIC CONNTION?
ALL OF THEM ARE ACTUALLY
HORRIBLE IF IT IS NOT A
CROSS-SECTION OF AMERICA, THESE
ARE WORSE PEOPLE.
JOSEPH ROSENBAUM?
THE MEDIA TELLS YOU THE MAIN
VICTIM IS A GUY CALLED GAGE
POINTED A LOADED GUN IN HIS FACE
FOR WHICH HE'S NEVER BEEN
CHARGED, BY THE WAY.
WHO IS THIS GUY?
TURNS OUT ALSO IS A LENGTHY
CRIMINAL HISTORY THAT INCLUDESAN
GRANDMOTHER IN THE FACE.
JUST SIX DAYS BEFORE HE
TESTIFIED IN THE TRIAL WHICH
JOE BIDEN SAYS IS NOT A BIG DEAL
BUT MOST PEOPLE ARE TNKING WE
ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO DO THAT.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO, WAS CHARGED
WITH SMASHING THE BEDROOM WINDOW
OF HIS EX-GIRLFRIEND'S HOME AT
4:00 A.M.
ON THE NIGHT KYLE RITTENHOUSE
SHOT HIM, HE ADMITTED HE WAS
CARRYING AN ILLEGAL FIREARM.
NO LONGER A BIG DEAL EITHER.
SOME CRIMES DON'T MATTER.
SO DID THE LAST GUY ANTHONY
UBER, THE MAN WHO HIT KYLE
RITTENHOUSE TWICE IN THE HEAD
WITH A SKATEBOARD.
WHO IS HE?
A CONVICTED DOMESTIC ABUSER.
HE ONCE TOLD HIS BROTHER IF HE
DIDN'T CLEAN THE ROOM IN HIS
HOUSE, HE WAS GOING TO GOT HIM
LIKE A PIG.
HE SAID THAT WHILE HE WAS
HOLDING A SIX-INCH KNIFE TO HIS
BROTHER STOMACH AND THEN HE
GRABBED HIS BROTHER'S NECK AND
SAID I'M GOING TO BURN THIS
HOUSE DOWN WITH ALL OF YOU IN
IT.
HE PLEADED GUILTY TO ONE COUNT
OF STRANGULATION.
SO I GUESS THE POINT IS PRETTY
SIMPLE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF VIOLENT
CRIMINALS AT THIS PARTICULAR
JOE BIDEN RALLY IN KENOSHA,
WISCONSIN, WHAT ARE THE ODDS OF
THAT?
KIND OF HARD NOT TO CONTRAST IT
TH WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6TH, THE INSURRECTION
THEY NEVER STOP TELLING US
ABOUT.
NO ONE HAS BEEN CHARGED WITH
CARRYING A GUN INSIDE THE
CAPITOL BUILDING.
HOW MANY FIRES THAT THEY SET?
NO THAT WE ARE AWARE OF BUT
THEY GET TO ROT IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT WHILE HE GETS A SEAL
OF APPROVAL FROM MSNBC ANCHORS
FOR POINTED A LOAD GUN IN THE
FACE OF A CHILD.
SO THE TRIALS WRAPPING UP, THE
PEOPLE WHO ENGINEERED THE
POLITICAL PROSECUTION BEHIND
THIS ARETILL IN POWER.
ONE OF THE MAIN TAKEAWAYS FROM
ALL OF THIS IS T